außerirdisches leben auf der erde
forscher haben jetzt in den größten
kristall formationen der welt lebensraum
entdeckt die an sonst nirgends vorkommen
wie und wo diese organismen überleben
das sollte bei pixum science fiction
herzen kommt das leben findet seinen weg
und war auch an orten in denen wir
eigentlich kein leben vermuten würden
immer wieder gift die wissenschaftler
überrascht wo die spuren von leben
findet und wie viele dieser orte sind
für menschen ohne die hilfe von
technischer ausrüstung tödlich so zb in
der mine von nike ab das bergwerk liegt
im mexikanischen bundesstaat chihuahua
durch die erreicht man in 120 bis 290
meter tiefe natürlich höhen in denen man
riesige halle aus marien glaubten marin
lag ist ein wasserhaltiges calciumsulfat
umgangssprachlich gibt dies sind die
größten kristalle der welt sind rund 14
meter lang und wiegen rund 50 kommen die
umgebung in diesen höhen ist zufrieden
dass ein mensch hier schnell zu tode
kommen kann
50 grad celsius beträgt die temperatur
die luftfeuchtigkeit liegt bei rund 99
prozent führt dazu dass weiß nicht
verdampft sondern der wasserdampf der
luft auf der haut content wird und die
körpertemperatur in die höhe 3 1 team um
die nasa astrobiologin und öl forscherin
penelope boston hat unter diesen
schwierigen bedingungen dennoch leben
dort unten gefunden einwänden der höhle
leben mikroorganismen aber es geht noch
extremer
das team hat auch herausgefunden dass es
in den kristallen blasen gibt in denen
flüssigkeit eingeschlossen ist und das
sensationelle darin fanden die forscher
weitere mikroorganismen sollte sich nach
einer prüfung herausstellen dass ihre
proben nicht durch mikroben von den
felswänden ja kontaminiert wurden dann
wäre dies ein einmaliger von quasi
außerirdische auf der erde die dort
eingeschlossen mikroben müssten dann
dort seit mindestens 50.000 jahren
überdauert haben die forscher erweckten
die organismen auf ihrer basis wieder
zum leben sie konnten
100 verschiedene arten entdeckt 90 war
vorher sogar komplett unbekannt gewesen
bei einem großteil handelte sich um
bakterien die forscher sind sich aber
sicher dass die mikroorganismen andere
sind als die von den wänden die
unterschiede seien bei allen
gemeinsamkeiten doch so signifikant groß
dass die wissenschaftler sagen können
dass es sich um eigene arten handelt
konnten auch keine ähnlichen neben vom
außerhalb dieser sehr speziellen
ökosysteme gefunden werden das alter der
mikroben konnten die forscher durch das
wachstum der köpft halle bestimmen dass
marin glas hat ein alter von ungefähr
einer halben million jahre da die
mikroorganismen in diesen tiefen ohne
sonnenlicht auskommen müssen können sie
keine photosynthese betreiben betreiben
sie die mogel käse auch teemu pukki
genannt dazu nutzen die
schienenverbindungen aus den kristallen
um diese in einer redaktion in energie
zu bangen die sie nutzen können das ist
schon ein sehr spektakulärer ort an dem
diese mikroben existieren das ist was so
auch außerirdisches leben existieren
könnte
ja und bitte beachtet die astrobiologen
der nasa haben sich schon das eine oder
andere mal gehört also das muss wirklich
noch verifiziert werden um wirklich zu
wissen stimmt das so oder stimmt das
nicht aber wenn es sich bestätigt dann
ist es wirklich quasi das sind es
außerirdische auf der erde denn unter
diesen bedingungen so lange zu überleben
das ist schon wirklich was spezielles
und das könnte hinweise darauf ergeben
ja einerseits wie außerirdisches leben
auch unter bedingungen wie auf dem mars
oder den anrainern jupitermond überleben
könnte und es könnte auch aufzeigen wie
leben von einem zum anderen planeten
jahr wandern könnte über aktuell um zu
weit wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollt wie
es verifiziert wird und wie eine weitere
meldung hier veröffentlichen dann drückt
nun aber aufs auge und hausen einen auch
die glocke guckt euch dieses video auch
noch an und ansonsten bis zum nächsten
mal gesagt bleib dran